foreign
ale hi Patricia how are you
I'm doing well hi Dave hi John hi well
how can we help
okay so I'm hoping you can help me solve
a debate with my husband okay we both
have really good incomes between us both
there's like 220k we have some savings
160k
um we are debt-free we're doing 15 of
growth into Investments
um stock Investments and we're at this
point now looking for a home
you don't own a home
no we don't we live in a one-bedroom
apartment right now okay
so the house that I would like to move
into is about like 400 to 450 and the
health and my husband would like to move
into is about 250k
um we've seen some in this area they're
really small they're really ugly um
okay your phone's breaking up you're
going to speak directly into it you saw
some in this area that what
we saw them in the area that are 250k
this is my husband's Branch yeah and
they're you make 225 000 a year you have
150 000 in savings
yes what do you guys do for a living
oh so I work as a software developer at
University stock Trader he works as a
what
a stock trainer stock Trader of Betty
does okay and
um
yeah how long you all been married
of three years okay
all right and so he he's what 26
no he's 47. 47.
I'll miss that one why does he want to
buy a 250 000 house
because he's a cheapskate and he's a
player
into a multi-family home yeah he's a
player he's a stock Trader yeah he's got
a oh he's got does he always have a
scheme on top of a scheme on top of the
ski that he does yeah okay here's the
thing
um my advice to your husband
is that you separate being a player
from where you live
okay
p-l-a-y-a yeah
from where you need to separate it from
where you live
because you don't play with your home
this is where you live with your animals
your future children and God help you
your wife okay
this is where you live you don't play
high risk
maximize investment games with your home
it's a safe haven it's a place it
happens to be a good investment but it
is not a speculative we're going to make
a bunch of money investment in the short
term and that's how his brain works so I
know this guy because I used to be him
that's why I said 26 because when I was
26 I did the same thing we moved so much
our furniture was trained to jump on the
truck
because I was a player I was always
wanting to do some deal and I pulled my
poor wife around by the hair on her head
and she went along with it and we've
been married 40 years and she tell 40
years she now tells people we've had 33
good years of marriage she doesn't count
the first seven right and that's because
of stuff like this right here so I can
speak directly to him I was him when I
had hair okay that's it so the uh the
best thing he can do is separate
relationally psychologically investment
philosophy separate your home from your
investment mentality
it happens to also be a good investment
by the way but you need to separate it
out that's my advice to him and my
advice to him also is happy wife happy
life you guys can afford a 450 000 house
he needs to go get a 450 000 house and
then he needs to do his other stuff
after he gets that house paid for
you win the argument
hey Patricia are you is he always
running a scam does he always have a
thing going there's always something I
think you've been married three years at
some point you need to have that
conversation because this will keep
coming up and it'll come up in all sorts
of different areas when your parents
start aging when you've got to think
about retirement facilities it's always
going to be another thing you have to
sit down and like Dave said you've got
to be really clear and intentional about
boundaries we joke about it now at our
house Patricia but when I'll start
working on something if Sharon smells
that she looks at me and she says you're
scheming and scamming
and meaning I'm trying to I'm trying to
use my intellect my mathematical skills
to out finagle reality
and that's what she's telling me you
hear me
in other words I'm violating Common
Sense here because I'm starting to just
go off in some little corner of
something with some math riddle and
figure out a way that I can maximize
something that wasn't intended to be
maximized like the place you live or to
get what you want right yeah yeah so if
he wants to do fixes and flips he should
do that with cash after your personal
residence is paid for and is a
sufficient resident you've been living
three years in a one bedroom apartment
you make a quarter of a million dollars
a year you've already sacrificed
time to get a nice house 15-year fixed
where the payments no more than a fourth
of your take-home pay this is the Ramsey
Show